we want to be segregation in our pants
unless our children begin to learn
together our people will never learn to
live together I'm excited about the
possibility of charter schools
integrating students
ps8 in Brooklyn Heights is one of New
York City's most sought-after public
elementary schools it's surrounded by
luxury condominiums in
nineteenth-century townhouses young
families pay top dollar to move into the
zone with the goal of laying claim to
one of psas coveted kindergartner spots
three-quarters of a mile from PS 8 is
another Elementary School called PS 307
it serves a tiny section of Brooklyn but
on the map looks like it was carved out
of the area signed to PS 8 and the zone
is fully occupied by a public housing
project as a result demographically
these two schools just a short distance
apart look nothing alike many more of PS
307 students come from economically
disadvantaged homes and the school has a
significantly larger minority population
and there's nothing unusual about this
particular district race and class
divisions exist in public schools all
over America 62 years after the Supreme
Court ruled against separate-but-equal
school lines are drawn in a way that
keeps kids rich and poor black and white
apartment
Wendy lekker is a senior attorney at the
education Law Center we have been
steadily resegregate and our schools now
are more segregated today than they've
been in 40 years the public schools have
always at least in theory been the glue
that holds our society together richard
collenberg is a senior fellow at the
left-leaning Century Foundation if we
have a system where everyone goes off to
their own school then we've lost
something significant in our society now
in this particular district in Brooklyn
with ps8 experiencing severe
overcrowding the community is making a
serious attempt to bring more
integration
this is a single instance what we have
an opportunity to say that we believe in
diversity and we want to leave
segregation in our past
in early January local board that
represents the district voted six to
three to redraw the boundary between PS
8 and PS 307 in theory this will mean
hundreds of white affluent families will
start sending their kids to a school
that's currently predominantly poor and
minority but will parents go along with
the plan
Richard collenberg says the rezoning may
not lead to the desired result I don't
know what will happen in this particular
case but in general the lesson of
integration over the past 30 or 40 years
has been don't just compulsorily
reassign families and expect integration
to occur upper-middle class families
have options they can move to a
different district they can send their
children to private school one of the
neighborhoods reassigned from PS 8 to PS
307 is called Dumbo which happens to be
the most expensive place to live in all
of Brooklyn listen to the public
feedback and vote no on the rezoning
proposal for 2016-17 one parent from the
neighborhood was quoted in the New York
Times saying he would consider sending
his child to the school but is it at the
level of a PS 8 however it's not truly
clear another parent characterized PS
307 is severely underperforming adding I
don't want to be the bad guy in the room
but no one else wants to talk about it
parents know the evidence which suggests
that the biggest predictor of academic
achievement is the socioeconomic status
of the family a child comes from the
second biggest predictor is the
socioeconomic status of the peers in a
school if a view middle-class kids end
up in an extremely high poverty school
they may not end up doing very well we
could improve schools altogether when
we're all in the same boat
Wendy lekker on the other hand says
rezoning is an effective tool to bring
diversity she wants the city to go
farther and redraw the lines for every
school in the district to reflect the
reality that 70% of the families living
the community are poor unless you have
this clear every school in district 13
should be 70% economically disadvantaged
if not they're going to be imbalanced
aren't they if not if you have a 90% in
one and 20% in the other it's it's not
fair
middle-class parents have options what
makes you think that the parents are
going to send their kids to a public
school where 70% of the kids are
economically disadvantaged I think
there's a lot of Education that needs to
happen as I said schools have been
resegregate enforce so many parents
don't themselves have experience with
integrated education I have a little
more faith in parents that when they
look at the actual school when they
understand the benefits of at being in a
diverse school district they will choose
to participate in the public school
system but there is one school in the
district called PS 282 that already
precisely fits that bill it's majority
black and poor but the famously liberal
parents in the surrounding neighborhood
of Park Slope who are zoned for PS 282
have overwhelmingly shunned the school
parents tend to be most concerned with
the quality of the teachers and
principal when a school has a lousy
reputation upper middle class parents
find a way to avoid sending their kids
there but when a school does have
everything going for it those same
parents are notorious for moving and
aggressively and edging everybody else
out I don't like with any I don't like
what's happening those most outspoken
against the rezoning were in DUMBO
residents but parents from PS 307 and
those who live in the housing project
that it currently serves they say
despite its low test scores PS 307 is a
terrific school and now white gentrify
errs are coming to take what's theirs
line what we're trying to do is
segregate 307 all that we will give if
this plan go through is another PSA you
cannot take from the
that one there to give to others that
are just coming in what do you think are
going to take over I do you take from
her when you get older she's going to
take from you there are people who feel
like oh I will only go to this school if
they're not there what they say they
want they're actually killing Justice
Thurgood Marshall said unless our
children begin to learn together our
people will never learn to live together
the primary reason to be for diversity
is equity low-income students in middle
class schools are as much as two years
ahead of low income students stuck in
high poverty schools both Wendy lekker
and Richard Colin burr support an
alternative school assignment system
called controlled choice which has begun
to garner some interest in New York City
under this approach there would be no
intra district school zones so parents
who live within a district could apply
to all schools located in that district
and then each school would aim for a
diverse mix of students when deciding
who to admit Richard collenberg wants to
go even farther in disconnecting where a
child lives from where he or she gets to
go to school because charter schools are
open to students sometimes indeed
anywhere in a metropolitan area they
offer the possibility of higher levels
of integration walking distance from PS
8 in PS 307 there are already 3 charters
with diversity as part of their core
mission charters are public schools that
are free from many of the bureaucratic
rules that govern traditional public
schools and they aren't strictly tied to
a particular neighborhood so kids from
anywhere in the city can apply for a
slot the newest of the bunch is the
International charter school of New York
Matthew levy is the school's executive
director so we have everybody from
parents who work on Wall Street to
families who live in transitional
housing or their doubled up with another
family living in somebody else's house
while they're trying to find a place
diversity is something that everybody
should value but I don't know that
forcing parents to value it if you force
them to value it then they don't because
they chose to send their kids there
Levy's parents tend to be on board with
the school's mission my child was
actually going to attend another school
and it would have been predominantly
African American kids
Tiffany Jones's son Kwan is a
kindergartner at the school in order to
be successful I feel that the younger
you start being exposed to different
things that better
I was very enclosed and the stuff that I
was taught is actually like somewhat
very racist hanasu Drance Key was raised
as I had siddik Jew in a tight-knit
community she wants her son who is a
kindergartner at the school to be raised
with a different set of values not
everybody's like you and your judgments
on other people or what you think other
people are is not real it might have
been a month into the school year Kalam
was invited to a party by one of his
classmates I met someone there who was a
surgeon and I have a degree in pharmacy
technology and she was very nice and
gave me a lot of useful information and
moving forward I intend on getting my
certification and she gave me her number
and email and you know told me you know
Samia resume and it was very nice to
fill out next year's kindergarten class
levy has to sell enough parents on the
idea that the school is right for their
children I think from a parent
perspective diversity is kind of like a
side dish that you're entitled to if you
give out the meat and potatoes of a safe
warm loving school environment a
rigorous curriculum led by teachers who
care and know what they're doing so if
you do those things then you're entitled
to talk about diversity
today most charter schools aren't
diverse at all but collenberg believes
that if parents had more choices many
would recognize the immense benefit
and opted to send their kids to
integrated schools I'm excited about the
possibility of charter schools
empowering teachers and integrating
students and that would help end the
fighting after all these years over how
lines are drawn on a map